people say trust the process right but
it's hard to trust a process that you
have not been through before once you've
done it one time you have a sense of the
full scope of the process or what you
think is a full scope of the process
then you do it again and again and again
and you start to go oh yeah this is the
part where you start to doubt yourself
this is the part where you get excited
but uh like in Texas we have this season
it's called false fall so it's cool and
awesome right here it'll probably get
hot again right like we think we think
the Summer's finally broken but there's
actually like several more hot days
coming projects are like that too you
think you're over the hump you think
you've done it and then oh wait no it's
going to get hard again but you you you
start to get a sense of The rhythms of
it and then you can trust the process
and then you can also enjoy the
process